&gt;&gt; Notice that we have an equation, but we still have an unknown, this total
final volume. I'm going to use a bucket to try and help us figure it out. Let's
see if we can get an expression for this volume. We know, for our first volume,
we had 5 gallons. So, I'm going to pour those 5 gallons into my bucket. For the
second volume, I don't know how much of it I used. We're going to pour an x
amount of that. So, we know our final volume is going to be 5 gallons plus x
gallons. This is the amount of gallons we wind up in the end, our volume 3. Now,
that we know that the total volume is 5 gallons plus x gallons, we have one
equation with one variable. Now, we're ready to solve. So, you solve this. How
much punch mix should we use that's 80% water to get our 75% water punch mix?
Write your answer here. And I've already included the unit of gallons, so don't
write that.